ce cas de carcinome mammaire d'origine
hormonale a été traitée avec une main
sur le haut du crâne et une main sur le
sein concernés celui ci a été stimulée
ainsi que la moelle osseuse ou pour le
moment il y a des métastases pour
lesquelles le système immunitaire est
également stimulé avec quels résultats
extraordinaires croire on a refait des
radios mais tous l'avaient 10 passes
de nombreux patients adhèrent
aujourd'hui à des médecines dites
alternatives ou complémentaires qui vise
notamment à créer un équilibre entre les
centres d'énergie qui émane du corps
comment peut-on stimuler ces énergies
vitales
comment peut-on les harmoniser quelles
sont les bases réelles de ces thérapies
et quels sont leur fonctionnement
les réponses à ces questions suppose un
minimum d'initiation un univers
scientifique fascinant issus d'anciennes
traditions orientales un univers devenu
l'objet de recherche d'avant-garde mais
qui demeure pourtant une énigme pour la
plupart d'entre nous
premièrement ça t'en sers la respire et
comme cette guerre fut cité mariale
entre la nostalgie
l'énergie vitale
le sujet se prête aux images poétiques
de longue date l'énergie vitale est
symbolisé par un fleuve le mystérieux
qui parcourt toute forme de la matière
et notamment notre corps il accompagne
le cycle de la vie la germination du
drain l'éclosion de la fleur la
croissance de l'arbre
après l'été vient l'automne puis l'hiver
l'arbre vieilli et finit par succomber
tout comme nous
l'énergie qui circulent librement est
synonyme de vie sont tarissement
entraîne la maladie et la mort il nous
faut donc demeurer le plus longtemps
possible en harmonie avec notre corps et
notre esprit avec l'énergie vitale
déjà dans l'antiquité chinoise le
taoïsme enseigné que l'homme peut
découvrir ses véritables pouvoirs
en fusionnant avec la nature harmonie
avec son prochain harmonie avec tous
ceux qui l'entourent
car le même fleuve mystérieux parcourt
toute chose
par ces mouvements gracieux le mettre ko
east de tai-chi relie la terre au ciel
il la met à l'unisson l'énergie passe
librement dans le corps et tout et
bien-être
oh
selon l'expérience chinoise plusieurs
fois millénaire l'énergie de l'homme le
qui parcourent des lignes précises les
méridiens ponctuée de points tout aussi
précis sur lesquels il est possible
d'agir de manière à prévenir la maladie
ou à la soigner ses l'acupuncture
pratiquée sur des millions de patients
également à des fins d'anésthésie est
associée ou non à l'utilisation de
plantes et de minéraux
en inde la médecine traditionnelle
l'ayurveda se base également sur
l'énergie vitale ici baptisé prana
différents canaux secondaires les nadi
rejoignent un canal central qui relie le
bassin à la tête
symboliquement la terre au ciel en
traversant des centres énergétiques les
chakras
certains de ces concepts médicaux
chinois et indien se retrouve d'ailleurs
dans les thérapies occidentales
notamment l'intuition selon laquelle
l'énergie vitale est véhiculée par des
flux lumineux une des formes les plus
pures de cette médecine orientale se
pratique au bhutan un petit royaume de
l'himalaya dans son cabinet
traditionnels un médecin local applique
sa thérapie en se fondant sur les
symptômes que présente son patient
troubles digestifs et fatigue après
avoir calmé son propre esprit par la
méditation
le praticien effectué des prises de poux
suivant la méthode chinoise ce qui lui
permet de poser un diagnostic sur le
flux énergétiques du malade
il prescrit des herbes des minéraux est
aussi une méditation propre à mettre en
harmonie l'esprit et le corps de son
client
une thérapie 13 ignorer de la médecine
occidentale la méditation c'est aussi la
cure préventive pratiqué en permanence
parce lama qui prit en s'accompagnant
d'un tambour il développe en lui un
sentiment de compassion et d'amour qui
doit le mettre en contact avec toute
chose et en communion avec lui même au
sommet de sa concentration d'esprit doit
lui apparaître un mandala ce schéma qui
est censé reproduire l'univers
c'est le signe de l' équilibre accompli
image de la perfection ou produits
éphémère de son imagination
le physicien suisse jenny a analysé les
rapports effectif entre les sons et les
formes telles que l'homme en état de
conscience peu les percevoir
ces grains répandu sur la surface d'un
tambour se répartissent en forme précise
est lié à la tonalité des vibrations
avec des appareils très perfectionnés on
a abouti à des structures géométriques
beaucoup plus complexe comparable à
celle du mandat la vue au bout thann
au début était le verbe dit la tradition
on connaît d'ailleurs de longue date la
puissance qui exercent les sons sur
notre état émotif et notamment la
musique utilisée en thérapie la science
occidentale confirmant ainsi la validité
de beaucoup de principes médicaux hérité
de lorient
le neurophysiologiste japonais mode de
yamaha a démontré l'existence de
courants énergétique et de champs
électriques dans le corps humain
assimilable au méridien et au chakra
des études sur ces sujets sont
aujourd'hui menée aux quatre coins du
monde en allemagne à l'institut
kaiserslautern le physicien fritz albert
pop poursuit des recherches sur
l'énergie vitale et sur les phénomènes
lumineux liés aux champs électriques de
l'organisme
le professeur pop s'est penché en
particulier sur les hypothèses de
certains savants russes selon lesquelles
les cellules commune créée entre elles
par l'intermédiaire de la lumière les
bio photons et pas seulement par voie
biochimiques
si cette théorie se trouvait vérifier
elle confirmerait les fondements de
l'énergie vitale et ouvrirait
définitivement à notre médecine de
nouvelles possibilités thérapeutiques la
médecine orientale a d'ailleurs
influencé au cours des siècles passés
celle qui était pratiqué en europe
hippocrate paracelse ont témoigné de ses
apports venus d'asie à partir du xvième
siècle un renouvellement de la
connaissance a ouvert d'autres pistes
aux scientifiques
mais aujourd'hui quelques chercheurs
professeurs à nouveau que certaines
maladies pourraient trouver leur source
dans un dysfonctionnement bioélectrique
il faut revenir à ce sujet aux études du
professeur pop
nous avons entamé nos mesures dans les
années soixante dix c'était difficile
parce que l'intensité de la lumière
étaient faibles comme celle d'une bougie
observé à 20 kilomètres de distance
il s'agissait de démontrer que cette
lumière agissait comme un système de
communication à l'intérieur de
l'organisme
un nouveau système ultra rapide plus
rapide encore que le système nerveux
ou celui qui concerne les substances de
base comme les hormones un système qui
connecte toutes les parties de
l'organisme à la vitesse de la lumière
les images qui suivent constitue la
première relation films et de l'une des
expériences qui démontre l'existence de
cette communication par voix lumineuse
dans ces deux verres ont été déposés des
groupes identique d'organismes
monocellulaires ils sont placés dans un
amplificateur puissant utilisé
ordinairement par les astronomes et qui
permettra de visualiser la lumière de la
cellule
on peut voir comment réagissent les
cellules elle communique
ceci ne constitue qu'une expérience
parmi beaucoup d'autres
à présent la démonstration inverse les
deux verres sont séparés par une plaque
métallique
cette fois les deux cultures ne devrait
plus avoir la possibilité de communiquer
on voit qu'effectivement la
communication est interrompue la
luminescence de chaque culture ne se
manifeste que séparément
quelles sont les conclusions que l'on
peut tirer de l'expérience
cette méthode permet d'effectuer des
tests déterminants quelle substance
influence ce système de communication
nous savons par exemple que les cellules
tumorales ont perdu cette capacité à
communiquer elles sont devenues sourdes
à leur milieu ambiant
elles croissent de manière autonome la
régulation du système cellulaire
disparaît
nous pouvons donc se vérifier la
relation entre ce phénomène et la
malignité de la cellule nous pouvons
aussi utiliser cette découverte pour
influencer la communication autrement
dit pour intervenir thérapeutiquement la
communication se faisant par la lumière
nous agirons sur celle ci pour rétablir
les contacts défectueux ce genre de
problème n'est évidemment pas simple à
résoudre
en fait c'est très délicat on obtient de
résultats que grâce à une longue
pratique et a beaucoup de patience
les théoriciens et les chercheurs de
base ne peuvent seuls à porter toutes
les solutions le passage de la recherche
à l'application sur le patient est donc
rendue très difficile par la complexité
des processus vitaux des modèles
théoriques ont déduit des méthodes de
diagnostic et de traitement qui seront
ensuite testées et peu à peu affiné
voici quelques exemples de la mise en
oeuvre d'anciennes connaissances déjà
évoquée puis de l'application de
découvertes récentes ici l'acupuncture
classique utilisée par le docteur
elisabeth shue d'heure spécialiste de
médecine interne est adapté aux progrès
qui ont été réalisés en matière de bio
photons et de champs électriques
cet appareil note l'état de ses champs
électriques dans diverses zones du corps
de manière à orienter le diagnostic
destinés à mesurer les différents points
d'acupuncture
avant d'établir un diagnostic
nous procédons des tests avec cet
appareil qui mesure la conductivité
électrique de la peau dans chacune des
principales parties du corps cette
connectivité nous fournit des précisions
sur les organes qui présentent des
troubles énergétique et qui pourrait
être mal parce qu'ils ont été ainsi
localiser ces troubles pourront faire
l'objet d'examens plus approfondis
ils pourront être traités avec plus
d'efficacité
ici on peut tester le système
énergétique du poumon et constater qu'il
est déficient les clients des sens le
diagnostic est opposé on peut entamer la
thérapie light ce qu'on appelle un
balancement énergétique
nous allons utiliser ce produit qui
permet de normaliser la flore
bactérienne intestinale
j'ai placé la préparation dans un
récipient métallique pour les faire
pénétrer dans les circuits électriques
de mesures on pourrait aussi mettre le
médicament dans la main de la patiente
de contacts seraient encore plus direct
pour le moment il ne s'agit ni de la
vallée ni de l'injecter de contact
suffit on constate que ce remède
homéopathique din hm il réagit sur les
muqueuses avec un effet anti allergique
il permettra de rééquilibrer les
troubles énergétiques constatées dans la
partie gauche du corps ces procédés
l'électro acupuncture ou la biométrie
fonctionnel pratiquée par le docteur
kruger sont particulièrement novateur
les propriétés électriques des points
d'acupuncture se modifie en fonction de
l'état de l'organisme la résistance où
la conductivité d'un point peut varier
considérablement suivant l'évolution de
l'état général du patient
aujourd'hui et grâce notamment aux
recherches du docteur port nous savons
que les médicaments libère des photos
tous les médicaments même ceux qui sont
utilisés en médecine traditionnelle ces
photons influence le champ électrique
des points d'acupuncture
on me suit renseignements on peut
évaluer l'action du médicament sur le
patient cette méthode permet donc au
delà du diagnostic individuel de
prescrire une thérapie véritablement sur
mesure oui et on peut tout à fait relevé
la présence de prédisposition
héréditaire
indépendamment des troubles du corps
énergétique
cette expression a été inventé par des
chercheurs russes les chinois parlent
plutôt de flux énergétique le qui nous
pouvons aussi traiter ses troubles de
manière préventive avant même que la
maladie se manifeste dans l'organisme ou
un stade précoce
parce qu'il est encore possible de
guérir sans intervention chirurgicale ou
utilisation massive de substance
chimique génie chimique ont peut-être
éliminer les troubles de manière moins
agressive par exemple avec des
préparations homéopathiques
c'est un progrès considérable
en effet c'est une méthode naturelle
dans la médecine a besoin pour évoluer
des médias
ces nouvelles techniques intègre la
médecine classique et la complète elle
favorise en particulier la prévention
des recherches l'approfondît renforce
constamment l'évaluation positive dont
elle bénéficie dans le monde
scientifique
une autre de leur application est la
chromothérapie sur base de ces clichés
qui captent l'énergie émanant des doigts
des mains et des pieds
elle permet de dresser un bilan
énergétique du corps tout entier
le patient souffre de maux de tête et de
troubles rénaux
la thérapie consiste à appliquer des
lumières colorées sur les points
d'acupuncture et d'influer ainsi sur
l'équilibré énergétique du malade
cette fois encore il y as intégration de
la médecine chinoise et de nouvelles
découvertes liées à l'électromagnétisme
audio photo et les résultats ne sont pas
moins surprenant toutes les cultures ont
imaginé des thérapies qui utilisaient la
lumière ce que nous faisons n'est pas
nouveau je me suis fait cette réflexion
s'il est vrai comme le professeur la
médecine chinoise que c'est dans les
méridiens que circulent l'énergie vitale
nous n'avons plus besoin d'utiliser des
aiguilles il suffit d'agir de
l'extérieur en utilisant ce qui est
présent à l'intérieur de nous c'est à
dire la lumière pour remettre l'ensemble
en harmonie sur la base des lois de la
résonance et chaque jour nous apporte la
démonstration que cela fonctionne
la méthode consiste à projeter des
couleurs pures sur les points
d'acupuncture et d'autres points
découvert empiriquement par le docteur
mendel
les propriétés des diverses couleurs
sont utilisés depuis des milliers
d'années dans différentes méthodes
thérapeutiques et en matière de
recherche spirituelle
le docteur vandal a eu l'intuition de
les intégrer dans de nouvelles
applications
nous savons depuis newton qu'il existe
cette couleur s'échelonnant du rouge au
violet et de fréquences différentes
chacune de ces fréquences nous apporte
des informations spécifiques
nous savons ainsi que le rouge est la
couleur stimulante que le bleu est
apaisant le jaune améliore les
prestations intellectuelles les couleurs
peuvent ainsi nous fournir des éléments
diagnostic
cela s'est avéré de longue date nous
n'avons fait qu'adapter des
connaissances à l'analyse des symptômes
de nos patients pour appliquer ensuite
un traitement avec les couleurs
correspondante
et puisque la couleur à une fréquence au
même titre que le sont le docteur vandal
a intégré les deux éléments donnant
ainsi une nouvelle dimension sonore
cette fois à la chromothérapie
thérapie la crau mot sonne aux thérapies
utilise des sons obtenus en
convertissant la fréquence des couleurs
cette corrélation couleurs sont se
réalise au travers des vibrations comme
les sont toutes les couleurs ont une
vibration particulière une fréquence
lumineuse la vue et l'odorat sont
traités dans le cerveau par un organe
commun le talent hameau optique et s'il
a vu comme le doha sont gérés par le
même organe on peut supposer qu'un sont
une fréquence peut lui aussi induire
dans notre cerveau une modification qui
permettra de normaliser le processus de
régulation de tout l'organisme
les théories du dr wendel nous ramène
irrésistiblement aux méthodes du lama de
budan qui médite en utilisant à la fois
des formes des couleurs et des sons elle
nous ramène aussi aux expériences du
physicien jenny et tout aboutit au même
concept celui de l'énergie vitale une
vingtaine de minutes après le traitement
de nouvelles photos du malade confirme
le diagnostic du docteur wendel autre
méthode non moins surprenante la
kinésiologie le docteur alfred chat est
physicien il applique une méthode conçue
aux états unis et qui consiste à établir
un bilan énergétique en vérifiant la
résistance musculaire vérifions les
muscles toute la série il y à douze
couples de muscu liés aux 12 méridien
principaux que nous connaissons par
l'acupuncture le principe de la
kinésiologie et que des tests de la
fonction musculaire peuvent permettre de
déterminer la condition énergétique de
c'est observer pour lui appliquer
ensuite des traitements appropriés qui
permettront de corriger d'éventuels
dysfonctionnements
l'idée de base est celle d'une
reconstitution de l'equilibre
bioénergétique nous nous référons pour
l'essentiel à l'acupuncture pratiquée
dans la chine antique mais aussi aux
principes que l'être humain est sain et
équilibré lorsque ces énergies leçon
nous allons pouvoir nous rendre compte
de la condition énergétique qui est
actuellement celle de la patiente
le muscle est relié au méridien du gros
intestin
nous pouvons voir si le point
d'acupuncture qui se trouvent sur ce
méridien peut t'aider à bouger le bloc
énergétique
nous allons observer une autre zone la
zone neuro vasculaire qui active la
circulation dans cette partie du corps
pour voir si nous pouvons faire quelque
chose le docteur schatz intervient sur
les points d'acupuncture par des
pressions légères destinées à dissoudre
les blocs énergétique la kinésiologie
n'est qu'une des nombreuses formes de
traitement énergétique pratiquée
aujourd'hui
la réflexologie le shiatsu la polarité
ou le rééquilibrage notamment vous
constatez le retour une respiration
profonde c'est souvent le signe d'un
rééquilibrage énergétique
nous allons pouvoir vérifier le résultat
obtenu
la kinésithérapie peut aussi être
utilisées pour guérir des phénomènes
d'allergie parfois très pénible
il faut séparer le jaune et le blanc de
l'oeuf
mettez en bouche un peu de jaune
conserver le sur la langue pendant toute
la durée du test
maintenant vous êtes directement contact
avec l'élément nous allons observer la
réaction des muscles la kinésithérapie
est également utilisé dans des cas de
perte de mémoire autres méthodes
étonnantes la pran aux thérapies ce cas
de carcinome mammaire d'origine
hormonale a été traitée avec une main
sur le haut du crâne et une main sur le
sein concernés celui ci a été stimulée
ainsi que la moelle osseuse pour le
moment il ya des métastases pour
lesquelles le système immunitaire est
également stimulé la pran aux thérapies
très populaire utilisent des méthodes
non conventionnelles qui peuvent la
rendre suspecte mais elle permet
d'obtenir de réels résultats
le docteur jack à launay est un
praticien renommée qui a été soumis à de
nombreux contrôles scientifique
il a effectué des recherches importantes
sur les radiations bioénergétique en
collaboration avec des physiciens et des
biochimistes ces études sont comparables
à celle du docteur pop
elle démontre l'existence de ces forces
vitales qui se manifeste par des accords
musculaire sur un patient qui souffre de
graves troubles neurologiques
nous allons démontrer les effets de
l'énergie du prada en créant par
stimulation à travers une plaque de
plomb d'un centimètre d'épaisseur des
réactions ni aux chroniques
ces réactions sont spontanés c'est par
la pensée que l'on aviv un champ de
pratique
l'effet de l'énergie stimulent le
système central et provoque demio
chronique il faut noter que cette
énergie ne stimule que les muscles
malades les muscles sein ne réagissent
pas au phénomène
une démonstration surprenante d'une
force dont la puissance demeure un
mystère
que se passe-t-il entre le thérapeute et
le patient entre leurs champs
énergétiques
lorsque les deux énergies sont
confrontés il se produit un processus de
résonance et de réfraction qui ravive
les mécanismes biochimiques inexistant
ou insuffisant ce phénomène permet donc
de corriger un processus biochimique
actuellement nous tentons d'évaluer la
quantité d'énergie
nous cherchons à créer un appareil qui
permettent de mieux comprendre les
mécanismes pour pouvoir les créer
artificiellement les résultats sont
extraordinaires
les médecins ne voulais pas le croire on
ne refait toutes les radios et tout
avait disparu
je suis sorti de l'hôpital quand m'a
conseillé de venir ici de quoi s'ouvrir
et vous destinez et vous avez guéri de
cette maladie oui on a enregistré
beaucoup de guérison de maladies très
graves mais la prudence est de rigueur
je souffrais d'un mélanome à la jambe
gauche opéré il ya un an et demi et d'un
autre bras traité en février j'avais
perdu toutes mes forces toute mon
énergie
j'étais dans un état d'extrême très bon
je ne parvenais pas à récupérer certains
thérapeutes perçoivent par la proche de
leurs mains l'énergie de leurs patients
et post ensuite leur diagnostic en
fonction de leurs connaissances
médicales
c'est le cas du docteur johnny aimart
le docteur rhymer voit également
l'énergie qui émane de ses patients sous
forme de lumière de différentes couleurs
cet autre méthode rejoint celle de
certaines médecines orientales et les
recherches de motoyama et de paepe
rhymer perçoit les champs électriques
dans leur bande lumineuse ce qu'on
appelle laura je peux vous dire que le
docteur jersey rhymer à détecter les
maladies dont j'avais effectivement
souffert au diagnostic succès de la
thérapie
j'utilise diverses méthodes de manière
générale mon intervention consiste à
stimuler et harmoniser les zones
bioénergétique perturbé elle consiste
aussi à accroître la charge
bioénergétique
les diagnostics et les thérapies du
docteur rhymer ont été étudiés à
l'université de varsovie et en suisse
aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens ont recours
à cet ensemble de traitement
généralement définie comme alternatif à
la médecine officielle
mais ne faut-il pas considérer la
médecine comme un tout centré sur le
bien-être humain et utilisant toutes les
méthodes possibles
ne faut-il donc pas parler plutôt de
médecine globale ou holistique de
nouvelles recherches sont nécessaires
mais nous oublions trop souvent que
notre santé dépend avant tout de notre
propre façon de vivre
trop souvent nous nous laissons dominé
par un rythme de vie frénétique qui nous
agressent et nous perturbe
nous devons nous réapproprier notre
propre existence
prendre soin de nous mêmes
nous pouvons être notre propre médecin
c'est pourquoi beaucoup aujourd'hui
pratique des disciplines qui les aident
à prendre leur santé en charge ainsi le
yoga qui améliorent la connaissance de
soi qui fait circuler le prana l'énergie
corporelle
l'individu fait agir sa pensée sur son
corps il cesse d'être l'objet passif
d'une thérapie extérieur on multiplie
les séminaires sur les différentes
formes de méditation de stimulation et
d' équilibre des centres énergétiques
les chakras sur les couleurs les sons
etc
beaucoup ont recours à la relaxation
comme le training autogène on cherche à
redécouvrir son corps et ses émotions
propres pour développer une conscience
plus authentique
laplante a des racines et des feuilles
la2 chakra elle capte l'énergie de la
terre l'énergie de la mère et du père
elle se fonde pour que l'arbre puisse se
réaliser
il en est de même pour nous l'énergie du
père et de la mère
elle se fonde et se complètent et du
centre de notre corps cette énergie se
dissipe au moment de la mort
la couleur orange et la couleur du
contrôle des émotions il colorie
journées maintenant visualiser la
couleur jaune
les dates et laisser reposer votre
esprit comme l'enseignent la
psychodynamique d'origine américaine
beaucoup de ces techniques ont en commun
la relaxation du corps celle de l'esprit
et des exercices de visualisation qui
permettent de guider les sens la
visualisation est un instrument naturel
que nous portons en permanence en nous
mêmes elle nous permet d'envoyer à notre
esprit des messages qui traduit l'esprit
créatif travaillant sur un plan
imaginatif de cette façon nous ne
communiquons des visualisations de ce à
quoi nous souhaitons tendre
par exemple supposons une personne
timide qui désirent intensément acquérir
le comportement inverse
cette timidité s'alimente une série
d'expériences que cette personne a vécu
d'une certaine manière dans son cerveau
qui fonctionne comme un ordinateur
existe un programme timidité seyon mois
à travers un discours imaginatif je crée
une série d'expériences inverse
je vais substituer aux schémas de
timidité un schéma de comportement
correct celui d'une personne qui a avec
les autres une relation ordinaire
la personne en question se trouve alors
débarrassé de son problème sans qu'elle
est à faire agir sa volonté sans
qu'intervienne un véritable désir de
changer de comportement le travail se
fait au niveau de l'imagination puisque
par chance
l'esprit ne fait pas de distinction
entre une expérience subjective et une
expérience objectif quand je vous dirais
3 vous bâtirez autour de vous un
véritable écran avec le cadre de mon
sourire et en bougeant physiquement
chacun formule son objectif et le
visualise plastiquement sur un écran la
scène doit être imaginé dans ses
moindres détails pour générer de
véritables émotions ainsi se construire
une expérience ici la pensée est le
moteur de l'énergie l'objectif peut être
aussi la guérison
aux etats unis la méthode est utilisée
avec succès dans la lutte contre le
cancer par le docteur simonson la pensée
constitue notre force la plus
extraordinaire
ses seules limites sont celles de notre
imagination
nous nous arrêtons irrésistiblement aux
frontières que nous nous sommes
nous-mêmes fixe mais si nous faisons
l'effort d'élargir cette raison nous
réussissons à nous réaliser au maximum
ses couleurs
soto il est certain que nous avons
tendance à nous utiliser
nous avons la possibilité d'être
beaucoup plus que ce que nous sommes et
que nous avons été jusqu'ici motos des
bus ou des pensions
faisons maintenant une incursion dans le
futur les développements de
l'informatique nous ouvre des
perspectives illimitées
il nous est aujourd'hui possible
d'entrer dans une sorte de réalité
imaginatives comme celle qui vient
d'être évoqué et cela pour vivre des
expériences qui nous permettent par
exemple de nous soigner un casque des
lunettes un gant donne accès à cette
réalité virtuelle
m
la porte s'ouvre nous entrons devant
nous une sphère
nous l'observons sous tous les angles
le programme ne crée encore que des
images simplistes
peut-être dans peu de temps aurons-nous
accès à une simulation plus réalistes
comme celle ci créée au départ d'un film
traités par ordinateur
nous explorons de sentiments amoureux
pour mieux les vivre dans la réalité
pour l'instant tout cela ressemble
encore à un simple jeu mais ce n'est
qu'un début
ces techniques peuvent aussi inquiété
certains qui craignent de nous voir
étouffés dans une sorte de programmation
mental mais il ne faut pas oublier qu'en
la matière nous restons maîtres de tous
les choix
le docteur montego qu a élaboré un
système qui intègre l'essentiel de ses
expériences de pointe
nous allons créer une machine qui nous
permettra de visualiser les activités du
cerveau divisé en quatre grandes
fréquences électromagnétiques sur la
droite en partant du bas les ongs delta
en rouge les ondes teta en jaune les alv
à anvers et les bêta qui vont du bleu au
violet ses couleurs correspondent aux
différentes régions du corps le rouge
pour la zone du bassin
le jaune pour l'abdomen le vert pour le
coeur siège des émotions
le bleu pour le visage la zone de
l'esprit
ceci est un exemple pratique de la
manière dont toute théorie scientifique
peut trouver une expression propre dans
le domaine de la médecine et de la
thérapie l'appareil diagnostic un
blocage de la zone du plexus solaire le
chakra du coeur de la patiente qui
souffre de maux d'estomac
nous pouvons appliquer ici une thérapie
très simple basé sur le son et sur la
confiance de notre énergie vitale
intérieur il faut rappeler que les
champs électromagnétiques sont
parcourues de photons qui ont certaines
fréquences photons signifie énergie
lumineuse
nous les voyons dans une bande qui est
le spectre visible du champ
électromagnétique
mais les champs électromagnétiques sont
infinies il existe donc des bandes de
lumière non visibles
visibilité grâce à certaines techniques
nous pouvons explorer mentalement notre
corps devenir conscients de nos énergies
et même les voir c'est à dire devenir
conscients de notre champ
électromagnétique
nous fermons les yeux et nous commençons
à sentir notre corps à percevoir si la
fréquence que nous appelons des
sensations
les sensations sont donc des fréquences
qui arrive du corps au cerveau à travers
les nerfs sinon si nous fermons les yeux
et si nous regardons notre corps de
l'intérieur ce qui est une faculté que
nous avons tous mais que nous utilisons
peut nous commençons à percevoir les
choses de manière différente prestataire
technique se réfère à une musique à
diverses fréquences musique à quai à
cette jeune fille respire légèrement
avec tout son corps cela parle du ventre
du thorax jusqu'au cou au sommet de la
tête puis le parcours inverse
elle acquiert ainsi une perception de
son propre corps elle met en mouvement
ces énergies vitales et devient
consciente de ces blocages techniques
permettent une parfaite relaxation
elle libère les énergies autrement dit
elle permet aussi bien de guérir que de
prévenir les maladies et quinghai ou
stationné la gloire éternelle après 20
au son est ici associée la couleur
l'énergie recommence à circuler
harmonieusement dans le corps de la
patiente qui retrouve tout son bien-être
toutes les méthodes évoqué dans ce
document réclame encore bien des
recherches bien des vérifications
elle ouvre cependant mille et une
possibilités nouvelles à la médecine de
demain
elle nous invite à vivre en harmonie
avec nous mêmes comme avec les autres et
avec la nature
chacun de ces éléments formant un tout
parcourue par un même courant l'énergie
vitale elle nous est indissociable
chacun de nous est tributaire de ce lien
universal chacun de nous vit et
contribue à faire vivre la planète bleue